now our top story tonight that is the
safe reopening of America weeks ago
millions of businesses they had to shut
their doors millions of Americans stayed
at home life was seriously altered for
everybody in the country why to stop the
spread of the corona virus that was the
goal thankfully tonight the worst has
been avoided remember the devastating
models thankfully they were wrong almost
all of them
they've all been wrong some models
predicting as many as two and a half
dead Americans million dead American
city states cities counties never
experienced this unmanageable spike
thank God above now we hit the apex as
we thought we would it leveled off then
a slight drop then the dramatic decline
and those contracting the disease and
dying from this virus apparently that is
not good enough for many Democrats and
those in the mob
these fear mongers now they want all
Americans to languish in a nationwide
shutdown with no end in sight now the
mayor of Los Angeles and its public
health director both said the city will
never reopen until there is a cure
David Portenoy pointed out last night
what is now a viral epic rant when did
flatten the curve turn into finding a
cure before we open anything take a look
and the LA mayor we're not open in the
city till we find it TR what people have
jobs who've worked their whole lives off
to put forward on the table create a
happy living this is gonna go to
business they're gonna wake up whenever
this thing ends whenever the mayor's say
oh you can go back to work work to what
your company's gonna be out of business
they did a great job on Tucker show
powerful message now la if you want to
wait till there is a cure that's fine
but don't expect the rest of America to
fund your shelter in place until there
is a cure decision you want to make that
decision you think it's in your best
interest that's on you and you will have
to pay for all of that remember this is
the land of the free the home of the
brave most Americans are not going to
cower in fear but we will learn the
lessons that we have learned in the last
few months we did the lockdown we
listened to the experts even those that
were dead
every model wrong we did thankfully
flatten the curve we learned some
lessons some from success and some from
failure let's look at for example New
York New Jersey Pennsylvania Florida
Florida they mobilized the entire state
including the National Guard every state
agency to shield nursing homes and
retirement communities from the virus in
other words the most vulnerable they did
increase testing they targeted PPE they
literally wrapped their arms around the
most vulnerable in Florida as a result
Florida's death rate remained below 2000
even though the state has an enormous
elderly population well the exact
opposite happened in New York Governor
Cuomo on March the 25th made an
egregious decision that had deadly
consequences in New York now first he
made a lot of errors on he ignored his
2015 health initiative their
recommendation peak week you'll need
you'll be short fifteen thousand seven
hundred eighty three ventilators he
bought 0 the steady came up with a plan
to ration the 2,000 ventilators he had
the second big mistake occurred when
Cuomo mandated well if you wanted
hydroxychloroquine and as if throw
myosin and zinc it had to be
hospitalized to get it if you didn't
have coal but when you went in you might
have have it when you might have gotten
it when you left now the third and worst
mistake that came in the form of this
March 25th executive order took the
recommendation of the dumbest healthcare
quote expert in New York forcing nursing
homes and long-term care facilities to
readmit patients that had kovat 19 many
of the centers were screaming they're
not equipped to handle the coronavirus
cases they didn't have any PPP the
governor said well that's not my problem
you actually said that he said it's not
my job not his job to provide them with
PPE same guy that was screamin I need
40,000 ventilators meanwhile thousands
of hospital beds at the Javits Center
that the president built the president's
staff the president converted to Cova 19
capability and the UN USNS comfort the
hospital Navy ship also staffed and sent
by the President and
all the personnel and equipment there
covin 19 converted well they only used
one hundred and eighty two of a thousand
beds they only used a little over a
thousand of the 3000 beds at the Javits
Center nearly thirty the third of New
York's coronavirus tests came from this
bad decision that's thirty thousand
thirty percent of over 27,000 people
dying now Cuomo finally New York media
seems to have caught up to us and
they're now asking him a few tough
questions while he was spending his days
preparing his perfectly meticulously
made powerpoints he made those bad
decisions now they're beginning to ask
questions take a look up until today as
I am before you I can look you in the
eyes and say we did everything that we
could as a society you can't save
everyone
you're gonna lose people that's life
that's somebody else is in charge of
that much higher pay grade but we did
everything we could I want to make sure
the same is true until this is over we
did everything we could
that's life imagine if Donald Trump's
well I tried my best that's life every
people died almost nursing home mandate
was a disaster now it also was
duplicated in other blue states
now remember Cuomo put that into effect
on March 25th well March 29th the state
of Pennsylvania they followed suit on
April 9th the state of New Jersey they
were sent to Cova nineteen patients into
nursing homes and long-term care
facilities Michigan also implementing
other dumb measures but they wouldn't
let you cut your lawn in Michigan all of
these states now are facing horrific
death halls horrific infection rates and
as I said what nearly 28,000 dead in New
York nearly 10,000 in New Jersey let's
look at Florida a little over 1800 Texas
death toll under 1200 Georgia under 1500
those are all big states they all have
metropolitan areas they all have a high
percentage of elderly population they
did something that we should learn from
and that is they targeted the most
vulnerable New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania and Michigan
they blew it they put these people that
were most vulnerable in the worst
positions how do I think they did it
maliciously or on purpose no I just
think they were dumb and unfortunately
it was so dumb in New York New Jersey
and Pennsylvania they could have taken
some of those empty kovat beds with
Trump's personnel Trump's hospitals
built and sent them there because they
were available to them on another note
we can also learn from businesses that
never closed during this pandemic now
imagine I'd go shopping people always
ask me in the grocery store Hannity why
are you here I'm like shopping I like to
eat obviously and they're like Oh
anyway so I get to ask that question but
I talk to all the workers I go a grocery
shopping once or twice a week I always
talk to the guys the same guys at my
grocery stores every week were they're
stacking the shelves we never ran out of
food in New York or Long Island and
thanks to the workers that stock the
shelves the farmers the truck drivers
the Packers all the people in that
supply line if you look at all of the
manufacturing plants that made all of
the mass at New York New Jersey and
Michigan and Pennsylvania needed and the
PPE and the respirators and the gloves
and the gowns they never stopped working
they never shut down if they shut down
either the food supply chain or the
medical equipment chain New York would
be dead they didn't shut down but
because they were wearing masks in the
epicenter stocking the shelves in New
York and in our drugstores in New York
and Long Island people lived we can
learn from those lessons we can learn
from Florida we can learn from Texas we
can learn from Georgia and that means
that places like New York LA if you
ought to stay lockdown for months or
even years well your cities will turn
into ghost towns and America's economy
your economies will face permanent
damage now states that elect smarter
governors that don't tax their citizens
to death and actually pay off their
pensions and don't take on big debts and
deficits don't expect them to bail you
out because they won't be doing it and
as of now by the way the city of Los
Angeles Justice extended their
restrictions for three more months
needless to say Nancy Pelosi is quite
pleased take a look there are a lot of
people in Los Angeles County Doris in a
whoa
three more months I can't survive this
as a small business I can't survive this
is someone who's out of work well of
course I agree with the decisions of the
people on the ground in their particular
venue and location so yes it's it's
inconvenient but it's even more
inconvenient if you're going to be
infected or worse okay Nancy Pelosi we
know what she's up to she's playing
politics as she always does in fact this
week she unveiled a massive three
trillion dollar spending proposal
nothing more than a grand socialist wish
list with money for illegal immigrants
mail-in voting measures without the need
for ID of any kind banking protections
for marijuana distributors and of course
a trillion dollar bailout for blue
states that misappropriate your
hard-earned tax dollars she wants to
take your money take the money from
fiscally responsible red states and
redistribute them to states that have
more waste fraud and abuse that you
could ever imagine
New York New Jersey Illinois and
California and so they can then balance
their reckless budgets and start
spending all over again in other words
she wants to pay off their unfunded
funded pensions there's insane green
energy programs three of them I know
that failed in New York one 750 million
one 600 million and 190 million the
entitlements for illegal immigrants well
red states shouldn't have to pay for
that either so let me be clear no state
bailout as a matter of fact Washington
pay close attention you spent enough
money no more spending
we don't need infrastructure three
trillion four trillion in loans
available that's a lot of money let's
see how it goes and do your best to open
the country safely learn from Florida
Texas Georgia and learn from the guys
that was stock in the grocery store
shelves where I live that wore masks and
gloves and they never got sick none of
them Democrats are now using this virus
as a political weapon president rightly
calling them out take a look people are
reported dead dying with this closure
with the shutdown of a country where
they're in the house they're in their
apartment they're not allowed some
people are too tough on it they're not
allowed to go out they can't they're
losing
jobs we're not gonna let it happen do
you think your critics want you to keep
it closed going into the election yeah I
do I do I think it's a it's a political
thing in addition I think you're putting
money business ahead of lives no no I
think if the people that want to see the
right thing happened they agree with me
we have to get our country open gotta
get the country open by the way those
Medical Supply manufacturers they never
closed if they did we were done it the
food supply chain broken any capacity
New York was done we would have starved
to death
Americans guess what they're fed up
across the country they see what's
happening
we witnessed another big lockdown
protest in Michigan